so this topic probably doesn't sound
very interesting but I promise at least
someone interesting keep in mind that
everything I'm saying here is about the
most efficient and profitable design of
grocery stores so don't go complaining
if your neighborhood Tesco or Safeway
isn't exactly the same but chances are
the next time you go to a grocery store
you'll notice at least some of these
principles at work let's start with the
entrance to the grocery store Americans
in particular love shopping in the
counterclockwise path for this reason
the door to the grocery store will
typically be on the right-hand side in
the United States and the checkout
counters will be on the left in the UK
it's often the opposite for this reason
researchers speculate that this tendency
to move in one direction is linked to
the side of the road that the two
demographics drive on this tendency
actually works in stores favor as well
research shows profits are higher in
u.s. grocery stores and entrance to the
right it allows individuals to move in
the paths that they like and also
exposes shoppers to the most amount of
merchandise possible in fact Americans
spend on average two dollars more per
trip when they move through the grocery
store in a counterclockwise pattern this
may not seem like much but when
considering that every American goes to
the grocery store an average of 1.5
times per week or 78 times a year this
amounts to enormous differences in
profits the periphery of a grocery store
is also very calculated items that are
almost always purchased in a trip to the
grocery store milk meat and eggs are
spread out around the perimeter to force
the shopper to be exposed to the most
merchandise possible shoppers will
almost always need to go these sections
so the position of the milk meat and
eggs dictates the way that a shopper can
move through the store within the center
aisles some retailers will put the most
sold items in the center of the aisles
to force the shoppers to walk by even
more merchandise looking at the cereal
section we can see the principle of eye
level is by level in the ideal
circumstance the most profitable cereals
are put at eye level this often means
that large brand-name cereals are
putting these middle shelves at kids eye
level retailers will often put
sugary kind of cereal that kids will
pester their parents for often on the
bottom levels are the bulk price or
generic brand cereals those who are
being frivolous are usually willing to
look around for the best deals and often
have clear intent to buy the product
ahead of time it's much more likely that
individuals will impulsively buy
brand-name cereal than bulk size generic
cereal on the top level is usually the
healthy or small brand cereal usually
those who are buying healthy cereal have
clear intent to buy that cereal and
profits are often lower on these cereals
also a prime location for items that
retailers want to push is the end caps
or the end of aisles almost all shoppers
will pass these end caps because of the
perimeter pattern we discussed earlier
interestingly the liquor store monopoly
in Sweden uses this principle in Reverse
the monopoly was created by the
government to promote moderation and
alcohol consumption so one of the things
they do to prevent impulse purchases is
not have any end cap displays so that's
all the ways that the layout of grocery
stores is designed to manipulate you
next time you go to the grocery store
look out for some of these retail
principles and I'm sure you'll spot at
least some of them
there's no one definition to make
something a country with the sides of
countries and country is essentially
whether or not other countries countries